what was it about quartet that made you
want to make your first feature film as
director honestly it's the lady next to
me because I wouldn't have done this one
if she hadn't equipped pushing me
forward I've always I've come so close
to directing films throughout the years
and I've always pulled out thinking all
the script isn't write the script isn't
right and my wife says if you wait for
the script to be right you'll never
direct anything because the script is
never right so ultimately you just have
to say I'm going to do this how do you
feel your experiences and actors help
she drives well I think the best
directors have been actors I think one
thing that actors have in common which
directors are not usually sensitive to
is that we are asked to get it right
immediately all the time is spent
lighting the scene deciding what the set
is and the actors are sitting in their
campers or whatever makeup room and they
say okay everything else is ready well
now ready we're not ready for you then
you come on and they expect you to get
it right away and I think the most
sensitive thing a director can do is let
them fail let them try and fail and try
and fail until you know let them have as
much time as the other people had
getting the set right and that's that
it's the best thing you can do i think
is to have them allow them that comfort
zone
you